[Musique]
c'est donc c'est non pas cette fois
écoutez j'ai trouvé ce brésil ou le
juste le nom de savourer dit me fait
beaucoup rire se trouve le nom est plus
drôle que le sabre et du tout les mêmes
ce qui serait un groupe problème
attention quand elle jusqu'à 3
moyennement intéressant c'est le nom du
sabre et dit c'est que des trucs qui
sont intéressants mais pas trop une
sorte d'entre deux voilà quoi
alors au nom c'est drôle c'est des
mexicains qui ont racheté un restaurant
chinois pour faire un restaurant
mexicain
et oui au lieu de repos pour faire une
sorte de paysage un peu mexique à quoi
ils ont juste vis des sombreros sur les
pandas je vais manger là bas j'ai un
trou héréditaire dans mon sourcils ça me
verrais d'imaginer la scène où elle est
passée devant ce tableau lc 10 mai à
temps mais un truc qui fait que j'aime
ce que c'est un ancêtre mais qu'est ce
que c'est
j'ai construit une audience miniature
grâce à toutes les pubs que j'avais dans
ma boîte aux lettres moyennement
intéressant lui pour le coup on souffle
du nez mon chauffeur hubert offre un
menu de conversation le temps de la
course
quoi incroyable attendait la course du
road rage
je vais me plaindre de chaque autre
conducteur de leur véhicule et de
pourquoi ils devraient pas avoir leur
permis
ok la course de l'information je vous en
dirais autant que je le peux à propos de
l'alaska et de pourquoi vous ne resterez
pas ici assez longtemps pour voir toutes
les choses importantes qui lie à avoir
la course des leçons de vie je
partagerai avec vous quelques leçons
essentielles de vie à prendre ou à
laisser
c'est intéressant pour de vrai parce que
des fois quand tu quand tu prends un
taxi ou un vtc tu as envie de discuter
avec la personne ses coulisses des
choses sympas mais des fois tu n'as pas
envie tu mets les airs potes et tu pries
pour qu'on ne parle pas mon ami a
rencontré un étranger à un mariage qui
lui ressemblait comme deux gouttes d'eau
et portait les mêmes vêtements
c'est pas possible ça mais c'est comme
la vie avec le tableau quoi si j'en ai
marre je suis jaloux ils trouvent tout
leur sens est par hasard l'a fait chier
quoi moi aussi je veux ça au la
corrosion sur ce robinet ressemble à une
carte moyennement intéressant fort
effectivement je comprends vraiment bien
le nom du sahb aurait dit j'ai eu un
avion entier juste pour moi parce que
j'ai été accidentellement bouquet sur un
vol d'équipage
comment je me chie ray dessus mec je ne
sais pas pourquoi je me cherchais dessus
je trouve ça trop rassurant d'avoir des
gens autour de soi dans la bio sauf
quand ils vont fait qu'ils prennent
beaucoup de place ou qu'ils ont un bébé
dans les bras
mais tous les autres c'est ok l'antenne
cassés de ma voiture ressemble à un
bateau sur l'eau je vois je vois pas ce
que le petit truc blanc peut croire
c'est les remous de l'eau mais vraiment
il ya vraiment des vices quoi il ya
vraiment des vies ce mec c'est dommage
ma chienne a détruit son jouet cactus et
il y avait un cactus triste
à l'intérieur c'est quoi ce concept de
fer a joué dans un jouet c'est
incroyable il faut universaliser ce
concept vraiment cg alors ça ça c'est
incroyable je me suis toujours dit
proulx ils font pas ça en plus c'est des
fournitures hockey de meubles sauf qu'au
lieu de faire un sachet dans lequel il a
tout il faut que tu te démerdes pour
trier il te les mettre dans des petites
pochettes étape par étape
voilà là ya ce qu'il faut pour l'étape
une lie à ce qu'il faut pour l'étape 2
lie à ce qu'il faut pour l'étape 4 et où
ils étape 3 dans tout ça merde et
oublier l'étape 3 même ce système là à
ses failles
[ __ ] ces arbres ressemblent à des
brocolis vous pouvez pas dire ça oui à
faire ça mais c'est pas parce que le nom
du second est dit est moyennement
intéressant qu'il faut se lâcher comme
ça c'est pas possible ça tu te fais
cette réflexion dans les bouchons et tu
la gardes pour toi tu avais un petit
coin de ta tête tu fais au amusant
l'angle du soleil a retiré la forme
italic sur l'ombre regardez on a quelque
chose qui a écrit en italique sur la
vitre et l'angle du soleil fait que
l'ombre de cette écriture n'est pas
écrit en italique waouh je trouve ça
vraiment cool il se faisait bien bien
chier quand même ce gars ce jour là pour
voir ça
non mais qu'on soit honnête notre
réfrigérateur a que des niveaux qui
tourne donc tu peux atteindre tout ce
que tu veux facilement là typiquement je
me demande pourquoi tous les
réfrigérateurs non pas ça en fait c'est
trop bien en plus il n'y a pas l'air
d'avoir moins de place que dans un frigo
classique en plus donc ces gens et que
des avantages des fois je vois des trucs
comme ça j'ai un vieux con et on est
passé à ça que ce soit la norme mais
c'est arrivé un poil trop tard donc
c'est pas la norme
[ __ ] moi aussi je veux me l'a dit un
truc moyennement intéressant ce terrible
annonce trop triste la coque de ce
téléphone s'incruste pas
fatma sur le bureau c'est trop triste
c'est l'arbre qui vient de retrouver une
partie de lui-même en fait c'est fou ce
gars dans la foule qui porte un t-shirt
néons
[Musique]
ok il est très fier c'est tout ce que je
voulais savoir cette abeille à photobomb
et ma photo et s'est retrouvé piles dans
le bon focus wahaha
trop classe trop classe oit a appelé ça
ça me fera toujours un truc la salle de
bain de mon avion à une fenêtre quoi
désormais donc quel avion à défendre et
salles de bain très peu utile mais cool
quand même on profite on aime bien il
aura fallu mettre les toilettes face à
la fenêtre
hélas ont été incroyables d'un côté les
gens passeraient le vol entier à chier
quoi c'est embêtant
j'ai vendée se démerdent quoi un
champignon géant cuba sera trouvée dans
les bois plait-il 1 ça me dégoûte je dis
je et les champignons je suis désolé ça
me dégoûte cc non au dessus à doha
pourquoi ces adorables parce que moi je
conduis pas très bien alors je suis
content qu'il ya des petits gestes comme
ça pour que tu es une meilleure vision
et que tu rentres bien sûr la place
dédiée merci à ce brave travail oit aux
batteries c'est mon rêve mon roi sonnait
comme un roi pas sincère c'est vrai
pourtant il était un distributeur qui a
buggé et qui a tout distribuer d'un coup
mais qu'elle rêve mais c'est pareil ça
fait partie des trucs où je pensais que
c'était des légendes attendait et ce
qu'est un seul bris dit qui regroupe
tout ce qu'on pensait être des légendes
mais qui en fait sont déjà arrivés ça
fait pas mal de vidéos qu'on fait comme
ça on découvre qu'un truc existe
vraiment comme la dernière fois la
souvenez-vous la machine qui a
déverrouillé un coffre fort
automatiquement qui trouve le code
j'étais sur steam neige en est que ça
n'existait pas c'est un crois que je
veux se sevrer décret le envoyé le mois
s'il vous plaît à ça c'est connu c'est
un clavier ou dès que tu appuies sur un
chiffre tout les chiffres changent de
place comme ça même si un mec regarde où
tu tapes bas il sera pas sûr qu'elle
chiffre à taper puisqu'il change de
passer chaque fois très connue très
sympa très très intéressant pour le coup
mes grands-parents d'un puits vitré dans
leur cuisine
ouah c'est génial c'est des gens qui ont
appuyé un vrai puis dans leur cuisine et
du coup ils ont mis une vitre au dessus
avec une petite lumière et du coup tu
vois la végétation qui s'est formée dans
le puits au milieu de leur cuisine trop
classe et apparemment il ya un chien qui
s'est installée là 10 sur 10 parfait
génial hashtags je veux un puits dans ma
cuisine les chaises à mon nouveau
travail ont des routes
roller comme ça on peut bouger sur notre
chaise sûr que ça fasse aucun bruit
[ __ ] mais alors ça c'est comme le
frigo pourquoi toutes les chaises non
pas ça en fait trop bien pralong des
histoires de cousseau coûter plus cher
que des roues classique mais la chaîne
de papier starburst cd bombrun starburst
que je construis depuis trois ans ok
c'est beau gros level d'origami parlant
de ça donne juste envie d'arrêter les
bonbons en fait genre tu es là tu te
rends bien compte visuellement de
combien de temps à manger et tu te
remets qu il faut arrêter d'en je suis
trop négatif
ah ça c'est une tomate d'aujourd'hui
versus une tomate de ya 150 enfin tiré
d'une graine qui datent de 150 ans et
c'est vrai quand tu vas à la campagne et
que moi j'ai de la belle famille bref
qui ont des qui font pousser des trucs
dans leur jardin ils ont des tomates qui
ressemble beaucoup plus à ça casse à
elles sont bien meilleurs d'ailleurs
elles ont un goût et son hyper bonne
comme une tomate à la base c'est ce à
quoi et avec l'agriculture intensive
exter extrait les techniques modernes
les fruits sont devenus ce à quoi enfin
bref c'est c'est déprimant ses portes
dans la salle de bain de ma chambre
d'hôtel peut fermer deux endroits
différents
waouh 300 cuit je suis partagé entre le
sait du génie et c'est vraiment des
pinces quand même et en vrai il aurait
juste dû mettre deux portes coulissantes
c'est beaucoup plus pratique
enfin je pars chez taïder je suis là je
suis à pire merde là dedans donc je gère
un avion en fait bravo à son équipe b g
le tournesol géant de mon ami pardon est
ce vrai attendez après avoir rétréci les
tomates vous avez rendu les tournesols
géants
j'adore cette plante a laissé trop drôle
c'est juste sa tête est aussi son
comportement c'est génial c'est vraiment
une super plantes
je suis très violent mentalement mon ami
a collectionné plus de 100 exemplaires
du film shrek en vhs dans quel but dans
quel but
cette photo de mes parents en voiture
n'existe pas elle provient de deux
photos séparés qui s'assemblent
parfaitement pour nom mais c'est un cil
je gère ses parents ils sont faits pour
être ensemble pour la vie quoi ces
vidéos quoi ces bancs publics sont
réversibles tu peut donc choisir d'être
face au bateau ou aux gens non mais ça
non mais ça c'est ça c'est pas
moyennement intéressant c'est hyper
intéressant ça à sa place dans le sobre
est dit sur les inventions là pour le
coup c'est une invention qui est très
cool qui plus est hyper intéressant ou
alors vous êtes vraiment dur
ma copine est un cheval qui lui ressort
il ait aucune forme de respect pour sa
copie c'est super grave elle porte une
veste de la même couleur que le cheval
il a dit allure sans qu'elle violeur
scala dignité quelle indignité
voilà voilà on y revient on irait
excusez moi mais la surenchère en plein
coup de gueule c'est une mise au point à
cette vidéo cet spatules à un embout
métallique qui fait que quand tu la
pause le bout ne touchent pas pourquoi
c'est pas la norme
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai dû attendre 24
ans de ma vie avant de savoir que ça
existe ce genre de spatule
ça m'énerve écoutez j'allais me moquer
là devant cette photo con que je suis en
me disant à lol l'architecte il a fait
n'importe quoi pas du tout deux sens et
qu'une fois de plus c'est pour que tu
puisse voir le plan d'évacuation si
jamais il ya le feu et du coup le
couloir était rempli de fumée au niveau
du sol y aura beaucoup moins de fumée
voire pas du tout et donc tu pourras
voir le plan d'évacuation parce que
c'est vrai qu'il le plan d'évacuation tu
le regardes jamais avant d'avoir besoin
d'évacuer donc avant que de la fumée
partout pareil pourquoi c'est pas la
norme sas crawl c'est incroyable c'est
un magasin de poussettes et à plusieurs
sol pour tester la poussette genre en
conditions réelles qu un seul avec des
cailloux du parc et des pavés ça me fait
rire nerveusement je m'imagine dans dix
ans essayé dans dix ans j'irai à ce
magasin est incroyable le meilleur à la
fois passionnant nuls mon chauffeur
hubert dont les cheveux forme à 25
parfait jeu le plus d'anecdotes sur les
chauffeurs je veux que comme cette
personne on apporte tous une attention
particulière à nos chauffeurs de taxi
vtc tout ça il ya tout un monde à
découvrir chez sa grand-mère à découvrir
bon eh bien écoutez c'est la fin de
toutes ces choses moyennement
intéressante a qu'à très peu
intéressants celui-là et brand marrant
parce que c'est là où les gens vont
poster tout ce qu'ils ont jamais osé
poster parce que sa rentrée dans aucune
mécanique aucune catégorie j'adore
particulièrement six au brésil il ya de
tout quoi quel plaisir je vous dis à
très vite et ne m'oubliez pas pour le
sabre est dit sur les choses qu'on
pensait être des légendes et qui existe
vraiment je veux qu'on le trouve je suis
sûr qu'il n'existait pas je vais le
chercher en vain je vous demande de
travailler je vous donne des devoirs ti
scandale ou à laisser ciao
[Musique]